so the MGM plus slate for development
goes out I'm being told actually in the
next 2 weeks last year this came out on
the 10th of January it's a little bit
later this year we actually do already
know some of the projects that are going
to be on that slate but we don't know a
few and actually Mike Wright the head of
MGM Plus in an interview not long ago
did tease that they are planning
something big from the MGM back catalog
but he then laughed and told us he
couldn't tell us what that was just yet
now we know being regular side trackers
that MGM plus is desperate for Stargate
it really sees that
franchise as the Cornerstone for MGM
Plus's growth that if Amazon really want
MGM plus to become a major part of prime
that they will need Stargate they need